Peter Parker can't save everyone —
but in "Spider-Man: No Way Home,"
one Peter Parker gets himself a second chance.
Peter Parker, aka Spider-Man, is one Marvel
character who is as defined by his love
interests as his powers; he has had some of the
most iconic girlfriends in all of Marvel Comics.
From MJ Watson to Gwen Stacy,
Peter sure is one lucky fella.
And that's not even getting into
his various flings with Black Cat,
aka Felicia Hardy. Any time the web-slinger
receives a new big-screen adaptation,
a big question on everyone's mind is which of
his girlfriends will be present in the film.
"You're wrong about us being on different paths.
We're not on different paths. You're my path.
And you're always gonna be my path."
The newest version of the character, played by Tom
Holland, got a reboot to his romantic life with
2017's "Spider-Man: Homecoming." Initially,
Peter Parker has a crush on classmate Liz,
but things get pretty complicated
when it turns out that her dad is
a villain known as "Vulture." By the time
"Spider-Man: Far From Home" rolls around,
we watch as Peter finally starts
going out with Michelle Jones, aka MJ.
Their relationship reaches a new level in
"Spider-Man: No Way Home" when they officially
become a couple. But being Spider-Man's
girlfriend comes with more than the perk
of dating a superhero. As MJ quickly learns,
it often means getting put in harm's way, too.
During the climactic "No Way Home"
battle against Electro, Sandman,
and Lizard, MJ finds herself in a position many of
Spider-Man's girlfriends have encountered before.
Left to fend for herself on a tall
structure as her boyfriend battles villains,
MJ falls off and plummets toward what
appears to be certain death. But then,
something interesting happens that's
bound to give fans a sense of deja vu.
Arguably, one of the most definitive
moments of Andrew Garfield's tenure
as Spider-Man is when he fails to catch
Gwen Stacy as she falls down a clock tower
while he fights Harry Osborn in "The Amazing
Spider-Man 2." The death of Gwen Stacy is a
major event in Marvel Comics that is translated
to become an equally major onscreen event that
likely caused more than one audience
member to shed a tear back in 2014.
The event caused Garfield's Spider-Man
to temporarily hang up the suit and
stop being the friendly neighborhood
hero the city needed. He comes back
around to fighting Rhino by the end
of the film, but it's clear from his
most recent appearance that he's still
not quite over Gwen's death just yet.
When Tom Holland's Peter Parker is at his
lowest, the Garfield variant lets him know
about how he lost his girlfriend some time ago.
He doesn't go into detail, but we, the audience,
know who he's referring to. We know this
is a Spider-Man haunted by his mistakes,
and when a similar moment transpires
in "No Way Home," he doesn't throw
away the opportunity to prevent
history from repeating itself.
When MJ falls off the Statue of Liberty,
Holland's Spider-Man jumps to save her but
is stopped short by Green Goblin. Fortunately,
Garfield's Spider-Man sees what's happening and
leaps into action. He catches MJ, allowing her
to land safely on the ground. The scene lingers
on the superhero for a beat, letting the audience
really take in what's happened. He may not have
been able to save Gwen, but he prevented another
Spider-Man from losing the person he loves most.
Check out one of our newest videos
right here! Plus, even more Looper
videos about "Spider-Man: No
Way Home" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.